hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of the walking dead season 7 episode 11
hostiles and calamities and yeah we're
back on the blue screen here at new rock
stars so I feel like I'm kind of that is
a Walking Dead anyway this episode just
goes to show you that episodes that set
on side characters can be pretty fun so
long as it's a sympathetic character
finally Breaking Bad by playing Atari
and doing lots of science stuff yeah
science so I'm going to explain
everything that you might have missed
some Easter eggs and changes from the
comics so let's get started with the
opening images so this episode begins
with a close-up on this sandwich it's
the same sandwich that fat Joey was
eating right before Darrell bludgeoned
him back in episode 8 and I like how the
shot frames the sandwich with its
tomatoes spilling out two parallel fat
Joey in the background with his tomato
brain spilling out but also I think the
sandwich is meant to remind us of the
sandwich in the opening images of
another sanctuary based episode this
season episode 3 and that sandwich
reflected Dwight domestic routine in the
sanctuary which he used to distract
himself from the fact that he was really
more of a prisoner there and seeing this
sandwich splattered on the ground
suggests that Dwight's facade is
beginning to fall apart and notice how
the editing of these opening scenes
places Dwight and Eugene side-by-side
for comparisons there are two valued
sanctuary residents bracing for the
worst but Eugene instead gets luxury
treatment meanwhile a beating in the
prison cell is exactly what happens to
Dwight so really this episode starts
with Dwight and Eugene in opposite
circumstances in the savior power
structure but by making similar choices
they arrive at the same place I'll come
back to this now this Savior named Laura
calls Eugene haircut and that is a
callback to episode 8 when Eugene
awkwardly scared as Laura flirted with
Spencer
you like watching the haircut yes so in
a way this is Laura flirting with Eugene
now reminding him that she remembers
what gets them off he's watching again
and considering that we've seen Laura
flirt with Spencer and then with Dwight
at the beginning of episode 3 I feel
like that might be part of her job for
negan try to seduce these weak men to
make them feel more at home at the
sanctuary and then notice the author
that uz name drops here Hongbin
American down
this would be satisfactory so Vonda and
McEntire is a science fiction author who
has written a ton of books including
several Star Trek novels and I think
this sets up an important sci-fi motif
for this episode
Eugene feels like an alien in an
unfamiliar planet and like many sci-fi
heroes he has to use his wits and
strategic thinking to survive or at
least that might be how Eugene sees it
also notice how Eugene turns on the
stereo to play everyone's favorite
torture song but rather than immediately
turning it off like any sane person
would Eugene Bobby's head along the
music and I think this is an important
distinction from Darrel time in the
sanctuary for Daryl this song was
torture an ironic taunt of how dire his
imprisonment was and his rebellious
response showed that he would never
kneel to negan meanwhile Eugene
embracing the song indicates that he's
totally willing to play ball and then
right before the opening credits noticed
how Dwight stuffs this go now note into
his pocket right before negan and the
other saviors jump him this little
detail shows that Dwight still wants to
protect Sherry's involvement with
Daryl's escape even though he doesn't
yet understand why she did it or why she
would take off and throw him under the
bus like that that's love guys totally
pathetic self disrespecting love okay
moving on to Dwight in the prison cell
now this is the same cell that Dwight in
prison Darryl in and notice what negan
says justice crews you remember so that
means Dwight occupied this specific cell
both before and after Darryl did many
ways he never really left it so again
we're seeing some more parallelism
between the two DS which makes Meighan
later line so important
so negan's wrong here Dwight is actually
very emotional he's just better at
hiding his true loyalties from Egan and
negan's blind-spot for the actual
similarities between Dwight and Darrell
looks like it's being set up as a key
weakness okay so then we get this
interaction between Dwight and dr.
Carson and other than painting Carson as
this kind of antagonistic figure who
talks [ __ ] about Sheree in front of a
guy who's still very much in love with
her I like how this scene foreshadows
what eventually happens to Carson with
this little joke when Dwight grabs a
bunch of suckers as if to say sorry bro
but you're a sucker and then back in his
room Dwight notices that his fish is
upside down and in its mouth he finds
this pack of cigarettes that sherry left
behind for him you see that's her
lipstick there and if you look closely
those are Morley brand cigarettes so
Morley cigarettes have shown up
throughout the series and in a ton of
movies and shows they're a fictional
version of Marley's mole Burroughs
really Morley's were popularized on the
x-files which seems to be what the
Walking Dead is referencing anytime we
see these and before I move on it's
white takes off on the motorcycle we get
this shot of his reflection in the
puddle of fat Joey's blood this reflects
his guilt in this moment by losing
sherry who in turn let Darrel escape
that Joey's blood is partially on
Dwight's hand okay moving on to Eugene's
tour the sanctuary where Laura finally
gives us some answers on how their
social order really worked beneath the
upper class of Savior's people are
numbered based on what service they
provide with exchanges based on a point
system so they mentioned number 42
before he makes potato chips and then we
saw number 39 back in episode three he
was the red-haired guy who fought over
rations and this long haired redhead kid
whom Eugene sees steal something is that
man son remember Dwight looted their
bunk afterwards so the reason we're
seeing him stealing now is that now that
his dad is a walker chained up in the
yard
his family is left with no means to
provide for themselves poor kid can't
even afford a haircut so what's your
Excuse Carl and this jar of pickles was
probably brined from the cucumbers that
we saw in the truck from the hilltop in
episode seven so Eugene is feasting on
the spoils from the plundering of crops
grown by his friends always know where
your food comes from guys and moving on
to this interesting scene outside with
Meighan notice how quickly Eugene
returns to his lie that he worked on the
human genome
project and has multiple advanced
degrees that's what Eugene did to trick
Abraham and Rosita and later Rick and
all the others into keeping him state
worked on them why shouldn't it work on
negan now we learned back in season five
when Eugene told everyone the truth that
this lie of core to his character
unknown smarter than most people I know
I'm a very good liar and I know one
needed to get to DC this is what he does
use the trivia and big words that he
does know into posing as an all-around
world-class expert and seeing him return
to his old tricks tells us that Eugene
seems to be starting over with the
saviors and he's betting that his old
friends won't be around long enough to
rat him out or an ultimate theory this
act could be just an act and he's still
on Team Rick but I'll talk more about
that later now you may be wondering why
is Eugene being treated so well by the
Savior's whereas daryl was treated like
abusive pet owners treat a stray dog I
think this shows that negan understands
that different prisoners require
different incentives like when Daryl
took a swing at him [ __ ] knew that this
guy was an animal and he tried to break
him in like one meanwhile Eugene is
physically weaker more of an
intellectual so negan knows that with a
little honey he'll catch this fly pretty
quickly and even though this works
almost immediately on Eugene and like
another scene depicts the difficult
crossroads that he's at by having him
clinging for dear life to this jar of
pickles he's literally in a pickle in
this moment betray my friends or bring
myself a ton of pain betrayal sounds
good and then when Eugene suggests using
liquid metal to reinforce the structural
integrity of these Walker's he mentions
the title this episode bonus points
recover in their hood and protecting
them from peer trauma from hostiles and
calamities now when Eugene says hostiles
and calamities he's referring to the two
primary types of threats facing the
survivors of this world hostiles refer
to human enemies who mean them harm
meanwhile calamities are natural dangers
that come at random in other words
walkers and these are the two things
threatening Eugene in this moment the
hostile
saviors surrounding him and the
calamitous Walker's on the other side of
the fence and his solution is his
desperate attempt to keep both of these
threats at bay and really Eugene's
general fear of hostiles and calamities
is what motivates all of his actions
this episode and in case you missed it
liquid metal ideas something Eugene
picked up back in episode 14 of last
season when he and Abraham ran into that
metal skull Walker in the armory
and he struggled to take it down and
before I move on I love this subtle
moment between negan and Eugene there is
nothing like beautiful women it smell
good to make you feel human I wouldn't
even know yeah you damn you wouldn't
know anything about being human okay
moving on to Eugene's and nerdy not at
all sexual date night with negan's wives
Tania Frankie and amber
you may remember amber from episode 7 as
the woman who slept with mark who God
marked which is why she's drinking
herself stupid out of guilt this episode
and the video game that Eugene is
playing here is called yars revenge
it's an Atari 2600 game from 1982 yarr
is an alien insect thing who battles his
way through a wall in order to kill the
evil quote I'll which is how they
pronounce it later I always thought it
was coda but whatever and much like that
yonder and MacIntyre shout out earlier I
feel like this is another nerdy sci fi
reference that might apply to Eugene
like Eugene might also see himself as an
insect-like alien trying to wear down
this barrier of trust with these saviors
who defeats the evil monster from within
now Eugene's homemade science projects
fireworks display is based on actual
science the foam explosion is the real
thing that you might have seen online
using hydrogen peroxide dish soap and a
catalysts like sodium iodide and the
hydrogen gas and the latex glove
balloons is actually super flammable
it's what caused the Hindenburg to
explode and according to Josh McDermitt
on one of the takes the candle only
punctured a small hole in the balloon
sending it flying around spitting fire
in a kind of head of a show for not
using that take then notice what music
Eugene is humming here this is
Tchaikovsky's 1812 overture which you
may know from another famous fireworks
display in V for Vendetta
and that movie and comic series was all
about overthrowing an authoritarian
regime by resurrecting the famous
Gunpowder Plot in England when guy Fox
conspired to blow up Parliament in 1605
so the fact that Eugene has this on his
mind right now is pretty interesting
granted these chemical explosives aren't
that powerful and I don't know if you
Jian could really construct real bombs
to demolish a sanctuary but it might
mean that Eugene is plotting in his own
secret plan to overthrow negan I don't
know we'll see all right moving on to
Dwight searching for Shari in their old
house where Dwight confirmed that Sharri
was indeed the one who slipped Darryl
the keys in the go now note and he
learned why she did it in this super
heartbreaking letter she felt Dwight had
gone too far to the dark side and Darryl
would remind white of the good man he
used to be which would just bring him
pain so she freed Darryl and took off
apparently not at all thinking what kind
of shitty punishment this would bring to
Dwight but really I think ferry is
misjudging Dwight here like negan she's
assuming Dwight has shut off his
emotions when he clearly haven't I mean
come on lady he just brought you those
pretzels and beer that you love and just
look at his face every time negan kisses
you okay I get it those scars are kind
of hard to look at also remember how
last season there was some confusion
over whether her name was sherry or
honey now we know honey was just
Dwight's private nickname for but I like
how the show turned that confusion into
an actual plot point this episode with
Dwight later using the goodbye honey
part to frame Carson because really
anyone can call anyone honey even cranky
old doctors okay moving on to Eugene
gathering painkillers to make a poison
for Frankie and Tanya and I alluded to
this before but I really think Eugene's
new information is modeled on another
nerdy pushed around scientist Walter
White and Breaking Bad a character the
people at AMC are obviously very
familiar with before he became
Heisenberg Walter White faced his own
hostiles and calamities leading him to
suddenly growing a backbone and finally
getting what he want [ __ ] you and your
eyebrows just like Eugene does here
report directly to negan
which means you report to Rick with a -
I mean let's face it this line is
probably the closest Eugene will get to
I'm the one who knocks and yeah it's
super satisfying to see a beat-down
looser feel empowerment like this
looting all the pills and grim plea
gunky but if Eugene is truly getting
with power here he might risk ending up
the same way Walter White this and in
another Heisenberg parallel we get this
Breaking Bad style
cook montage using the powers of science
to make a very lethal drug and UV making
this poison pill actually reminds me of
the ricin storyline in Breaking Bad and
I would love it if the show ended up
taking this turn also the music that
plays here is everything right it's
wrong again by they might be giants and
the music applies pretty directly in
Eugene situation like everything that
had been going right in his life like
gradually building trust and a way to
contribute to his friends has become
wrong again he's back to his old ways of
lying his way into being valued ok let's
move on to this furnace scene so how
exactly did Dwight frame dr. Carson well
he clipped out the goodbye honey part of
Sherry's letter and left it in Carson's
office leading Meighan to it with negan
assuming Shari left it for Carson after
Carson freed Daryl to impress Sherri and
then Sherri escaped because she knew
that she would be blamed so this
[ __ ] story combined with Dwight
claiming to have killed Sherri when he
found her effectively clears both her
and Dwight pinning everything on that
meddling old Romeo and I gotta say that
is a very complicated version of events
that Dwight is very lucky negan just
accepted as truth and pretty crazy that
negan would just trust white so much
despite all the reasons Dwight would
have to still hate him that he would
take his word over that of this doctor
who presumably hasn't really ever been
mistreated or personally motivated
against negan in any way but again I
think that blind spot for Dwight is
going to end up being Meegan's undoing I
also like how the camera stays focused
on Dwight during this tense moment
between negan and Carson like Dwight
won't look because he knows he pretty
much sentenced this innocent man to die
meanwhile it's important that Eugene
actually sees this well he kind of does
he cowardly covers his face like he does
anytime anyone gets killed but it's
crucial that Eugene be reminded exactly
how evil negan is so that his submission
to him truly feels like he's selling his
soul now dr. Carson's death is a big
deal because this is a pretty
significant deviation from the comics
like in the comics storyline Carson
actually helps Eugene and the other
prisoners escape from the sanctuary it
looks like the show is going in a
different direction perhaps giving
Eugene and Dwight a more
have ark as they live under negan and
then real quick when negan says this
line cuz we are spared dr. Garces even
though he's looking at Eugene in this
moment whom he thinks has a doctorate
degree
I think negan is actually talking about
the other dr. Carson dr. Harlan Carson
the doctor at the hilltop brother to the
guy in the furnace that might mean negan
is on his way to the hilltop which isn't
good news for Maggie or Darryl who said
that's where he's headed next now these
next scenes from Eugene feel like true
moral losses for him like he refuses to
give the poison pill to the wives
because they'll use it on negan and then
he professes his loyalty to the big guy
and tips their freaking soulmates Oh
[ __ ] totally completely stone-cold me I
was making before I even met you I just
needed to meet you properly to know oh
that's so sweet
sure next week we'll see Eugene taking
that stereo and like say anything easy
straight outside Meghan's window now
seeing this cowardly betrayal is kind of
hard to swallow and I admit that it
could be an act now we'll talk about
that later but for now let's entertain
the notion that Eugene might be just
being honest here like it kind of makes
them
Eugene admits that he's a coward and a
man of logic and when given the option
to fight alongside an outmatched group
who shifts on him and doesn't really
trust him or assimilate into this new
community with a simpler view of the
world where he's in the inner circle in
the world top scientist where they have
pickles and natori I totally get where
Eugene is coming from I would probably
do the same thing and that brings me to
our closing images with the most Awkward
reunion ever between Eugene and Dwight
regarding me clamping down on more
so Eugene it's trying to bring up the
last time these guys interacted last
season when Eugene got quite the
mouthful and making this even more
uncomfortable for Dwight you beam is
slowly chomping down on the pickle but
let's listen closely to this final
exchange between the two regarding me
clamping down on the board Oh
just like you Yugi your dua
we're negan so on the surface this is
meant to sound totally bleak with these
two men selling their souls and turning
their backs on innocents to arrive at
the same trapped place utterly
completely on board with Meighan but
when Eugene says just like you maybe
he's not referring to the public
perception of Dwight as a loyal Savior
but rather Dwight's true self and
impostor plain an axe and waiting for
the right moment to make his move
because when you think about it both of
these guys are smart enough to pull off
the sack maybe Eugene refused to use the
poison pill because he's playing the
long game and maybe he cut off negan
before not because he's eager to show
his support but because he wanted to
perhaps be legitimized the question the
way and by saying I am Eugene you are
Dwight we are negan Eugene might be used
in some coded language like we are both
still the independent men that we were
before but for now we're going to
continue to act like we're with negan
and we're going to carefully pick our
battles to stay ahead of any hostiles
and calamities okay looking ahead to
next episode episode 12 titled say yes
probably as a reference to Rick's deal
with Jada's last episode to find guns
yes which will bring them to this freaky
ass Walker carnival with some American
Horror Story type freakshow walkers
seriously it looks like this show was
like oh right zombies are in The Walking
Dead so let's do a spooky episode and
from the sound of Michonne's
foreboding line and the sneak peak clip
dark things are waiting for them serious
and some lingering questions one do you
think Eugene really have gone to the
dark side or is it just an act I feel
like I've already laid out the two sides
of this argument just let me know what
you think and to what's very right about
white is there no hope for redemption
for him or is he just had it expressing
himself which works great for negan but
bad for anyone else trying to root for
the guy okay let me know what you think
in the comments and check out my other
breakdowns of season 7 episodes and
thanks for watching and if you liked
this video please hit like and subscribe
to new rock stars also please share this
video and if you really like new rock
stars you can contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons you guys are awesome
especially you Kelly Dunn
you can hit me up on twitter at a box
with any thoughts or theories you have
on the walking dead or for all the new
rock stars on twitter at new rock stars
for updates on our videos alright thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you